othman
do you have a camera
i do i'm just turning it on he's uh he's
at a park right now with this kid
there he is
[Music]
are you angry at me
hey man
are you are you angry at me
hey man i'm not angry but you know what
i'm saying but
he made like a little video with mine
brother can you guys hear us
yeah i can hear you guys so you're an
expert on the quran and the bible which
is you which one is more accurate to
god's teachings
uh definitely the quran why do you say
that we have young down here
young would think the bible was
preserved
i got you so if you look at the bible
are you talking about the old testament
or the new testament
new testament
okay so what's the earliest manuscript
you have for the new testament that is
complete
or somewhat complete
sorry don you know
i don't need to defend the
bible i didn't come here
this is this is something that is unique
to islam i believe is there i do not try
to enlighten people about the nature of
god his laws and the pathway to
salvation by talking about islam for
instance or talking about the quran
because the bible tells us that his word
is perfect and is a perfect tool for
breaking the heart art and bringing them
forward to salvation so
i i didn't come here i don't know
anything about the quran in terms of the
oldest manuscript to compare it to oh
our manuscript holder or none like that
okay yeah you just said you just said
his word is perfect right his word is
perfect yes okay so in the bible how did
judas die
you know i haven't studied that enough
yet to uh tell you i know he hung
himself um okay i know where you're
going with it and you know what i'm
going to do
you know where you're going you're going
with it because in one book you know it
says that his innards were spilled out
and in the other book it says that he
hung himself but you know i've done some
brief research into that and there are
theologians who could better explain
that it is not a contradiction simply
put in my layman's explanation is judas
hung himself and then afterwards he fell
from whatever he was hanging from and
then his bowels spilled open you know
once a human body
finished once the body starts to die and
starts to decompose you will know that
there is a swelling that happens within
the abdominal muscles um you know you
can you can ask any more about that and
so yeah there you know there are all
right go ahead okay look the problem
with that explanation is that it
mentions headlong do you know what
headlong means
look i'm not here to
debate i am here to tell you towards
what i know you you this is this is this
is the this is the issue like all right
look at this the only way we can do this
with any degree of validity or any
degree of like um there being
genuine discourse happening you ask me a
question
i do not know the answer to it just
because i don't know the answer doesn't
mean there isn't an answer and so you
don't prove anything because
someone who is a novice right i became a
christian about two months ago someone
who's a novice who hasn't had the
opportunity to study the bible inside
out but i argue this is everyone on the
panel okay with brother asking me a
question and then i pull it up a
hour-long video and then all of us
sitting down here quietly and watching
this hour-long video as someone explains
that the answer to this question is
what's your name my name is don don all
right so let me let me explain something
and then uh i mean this is going to be
civil like i'm not here to attack you
i'm not here like the bible a question
was just raised when i got on the stream
what's more accurately the word of god
and i was just explaining why i believe
the quran is the accurate of god you can
go home research for another hour you
can worship for months we've been at
this go to the one message foundation
channel watch christian preachers
pastors from different countries that
are experts in the bible we have three
bible study professors that came out we
had uh three islamophobes mr wood all of
them came out none of them could answer
these questions except for any very lame
uh workarounds but you can watch those
videos and you can see the answers
aren't there you can make up an answer
no that's not true
that's not true yeah
that you finished right now
you're gonna have respect
and if you don't mind let me finish and
i'll let you speak as long as you like
respectful conversation
let me finish let me finish what i'm
saying you're not going to interrupt me
don let me finish what i'm saying and
then i will interrupt you that's how it
works okay go ahead let me talk about
judas this is a very important issue
because a creedal issue has to do with
the one that betrayed jesus supposedly
according to christianity then he got
crucified yeah
as much as you like and i'll stay quiet
when you spoke i stayed quiet when i
speak if you don't mind out of respect
please let me finish when i'm finished
you can speak as long as you like okay
so
when we look at judith's death the first
issue we find is what did you do with
the money in one verse he threw it away
at in the temple and walked out in the
other verse he bought a piece of land
with it in one verse he hung himself in
the other verse he fell headlong
headlong means your head moves first
that means you're in motion if you're
hanging and you fall you don't fall
headlong ask any any
forensics expert if you like
here you have two clear contradictory
reports now i'm not gonna put you on the
spot go home look it up we can get back
on a call you can come to san diego i
can come out to where you're at we can
have a conversation but this is just one
example i have and you can watch our
videos we have tons of these clear
numeric contradictions the old testament
new testament ages that don't match
because the earliest manuscripts you
have are from 7th century the earliest
complete semi-complete manuscript is
codex anaticus which is from the 4th
century that means you have 300 plus
years where you don't even have a full
manuscript and all these are in kone
greek that's why they're run by
different authors even the authors for
example hebrews we don't know who wrote
it even the gospels are named after
people like the gospel according to
matthew not by matthew so here's the
problem this is all not preserved this
is why okay
i'm saying i cannot fact no single thing
you said right and this is this is the
problem this is what i was i don't have
a problem with someone with debate or
anything like that but
i didn't come on here to debate
the history of the bible i am not a
biblical historian and so i know nothing
you say to me right now in regards to
these things carry any weight because
how do i know
where the truth starts where the truth
ends you know
you're you're you wanted to i'm not here
to debate the age of this or the age of
that yeah yeah i am here i would rather
want to speak about what it is that our
religions say because i find it
interesting that you you the direction
that you want to take in order in
disqualifying um my religion or
suggesting that my religion is not the
right religion it's not by looking at
the contents within it but rather trying
to you know
break oh well well about the 7th century
and the this and that it's like hold on
wait a minute why can't why let's have a
conversation about something that i am
actually more versed on which is the
merit of the word which is what is
actually said in the bible and so i
don't know if anything you just said is
true at all or accurate and to be fair i
don't think sneko could you would be
able to verify that neither would many
of the dudes on this panel which is why
they brought you in instead of they have
to be a debate on i just want to hear
what he has to say apparently he's an
expert in the crown of the bible i think
you're going on the defensive but he's
not really on the offensive right now
yeah no i haven't i have to
finish i okay yeah so it's like no i'm
just saying it's like um you know
that's all like what
what was i supposed to to gain from
anything you just said me not questions
for me
if i if i can't respond to anything you
just said because these are not things
that i've researched you know i'm sorry
so don't respond okay don um again i
just want to be respectful and listen to
you so if you're asking me a question do
you want me to respond to it
don
my question is how do you get salvation
salvation in islam great question let me
just let me just clarify one thing i
didn't come on here to attack the bible
or catch you off guard i was asked a
question when i came on and i was
responding to that question i think it's
an excellent question now the reason we
look at text is because you base your
salvation on a message that's in the
bible if you didn't have the bible how
would you know jesus died or was risen
or god or not god you're basing all of
that on the bible and the facts that i
brought to you you can go home and
research i'm not putting you on the spot
don i'm not here to debate i'm here to
present a message i was asked a question
and i responded to it no okay
wait wait wait wait wait wait one second
let me add i do have a contact that is
more versed on the bible someone just
suggested a great idea that i admit let
me let me go ahead and see if he's crazy
the first thing is when you talk about
what is islam's idea of salvation it's
the same salvation that has always been
the message of all the prophets which is
you believe in your creator you don't
worship idols if you look at the ten
commandments that's what you find hear
oh israel your lord is one not three one
and it says the next commandment do not
worship graven idols that's exactly what
islam believes don't worship idols
worship the one creator do righteous
deeds live by the law as best you can
and you will be saved we don't believe
that somebody came and died for our sins
and were scot-free just believing and i
don't think you actually believe that
either but we'll talk about that if you
ask about what is the islam's islamic
viewpoint on salvation here it is
now i will say one more thing
if you
claim that you believe in christianity
and you believe in the in the message of
jesus and salvation where did you get
that message from
where did you learn what that is
from the bible okay so this is the
problem if the bible you're reading is
not accurate if it was not written by
actual disciples it was written by
anonymous authors with clear
contradictory reports then your source
is wrong there's a problem however far
more experienced theologians than me
have proved that the bible has no
contradictions
john mcarthur john mcarthur i have the
mccarthy study bible
and if you look it up it clearly
mentions and i've mentioned this in our
videos if you want to see the references
watch our videos that there are clear
contradictions based on copyist errors
this is john mcarthur's own words in his
study bible there are clear
contradictions based on different
different viewpoints john mcarthur says
in the book of introduction of the book
of hebrews that the author is unknown
that's john mcarthur well no we we are
aware that the books
said there are no contradictions when i
just showed you that the one you
mentioned
there's obvious error contradictions now
you're jumping from it no you didn't
show me anything one didn't show me
anything you just said something look up
look up the mccarthy study bible look up
the introduction to hebrews and see what
he says you have it look it up right now
okay my point and he may have said that
i don't know
earlier earlier he said there's no
contradiction
okay
okay all right
here let me tell you this let me tell
you this i'm going to be
you may be smarter than me
i didn't claim that you finished can i
finish
you smarter than me you maybe you have
putting so much time and effort into you
know researching things in regards to
ways to try and make the bible look
illegitimate and all of that but here's
what i know for a fact is that
christianity is the one true religion
no i do you know what you can believe as
a fact all right so let him finish let
the man finish please
here's what i know for a fact
christianity is the one true religion
jesus christ is god and in the end we
will be judged and
ultimately i have complete security in
my salvation
and so
it is not my goal it is not my my job to
convince people because the bible says
that no man is capable of convincing
someone or saving someone only god can
do that only jesus can do that okay it's
not
no go ahead go ahead go ahead man no
because nico like cut me off and i'm
like
do you have someone that's a bit more
educated on the topic you could bring
into the call as well
okay let me let me ask you something don
can you can you pull up on your bible or
let me ask something first you said
jesus is god that's a fact you said
right yes okay do you also agree as the
old testament mentions that god knows
everything
yes okay can you bring up mark 13 32
please
mark 13 32 sure yes please
while he's doing that i'm going to go
pray makarov shall i'll be back in
france
nico my son's a fan man he wants to say
what's up hey man i haven't seen your
videos
that was kind of disrespectful bro like
that we're cleaning up today i didn't
realize what i was doing i was trying to
make fun of haram i didn't i did not
mean to mock the religion i'm so good
all right so what is what is you said
mark what
1332 mark 1332 i'm gonna bring it up too
thank you
y'all y'all gonna post this this video
it's live on youtube all right
okay so mark 13 32 says what of that day
or hour no one knows not even the angels
in heaven nor the son nor the father
alone
okay so how could jesus be god and you
said god knows everything and he not no
power well it's because god is a trinity
and so jesus was the
was fully human and fully god and so
in assuming this
in assuming this
in assuming this human state there were
certain limitations that were
accepted upon him so that he may come
and be the ultimate sacrifice you know
god god also doesn't get hungry right
god also doesn't get tired but yes i
agree god the father at that time
no no no it's not that he was no longer
god he was fully god and fully human the
limitations that he opposed on himself
were his choice because he is god and he
was able to do that he came
so he came to the earth so that he may
suffer and so that he may
experience life exactly as we experience
it the bible talks about him being
tempted and needing to rest so that we
were we would be able to look towards
him as
as an example of how we may strive to
live our lives now it's a it's a
standard we will never reach but he was
a display of what it would look like to
live a perfect life and so in order for
him to be able to be that example he
would have to experience all of the
limitations that we experience as people
okay so don let me just clarify this for
everybody listening and for you
if you're saying that he was fully god
while on earth that means he has to know
everything because you agreed god knows
everything the father is everything hold
on cece this is where this is where
you're jumping now earlier you said god
thing and then you said jesus is god now
you're changing to saying the father
knows everything not jesus no that means
you have also there's three persons no
god is three persons in one right god
has three persons in one he's the father
he is the son and he's the holy spirit
each person yes okay so now
each person has a has a specific okay
all right all right brother i mean you
you made a good point earlier about not
cutting each other off right let me can
i reply to what you were saying
all right yes each person has of the
godhead has a specific role and purpose
in that and so jesus came to die for our
sins and also to be the mediator to the
father no one may come to the father
except through me the holy spirit the
holy spirit came to dwell within us to
change our character and to be our guide
to be our helper to give us spiritual
discernment and so the father the father
for instance doesn't reside in all of us
you know the father lives within a realm
that cannot contain
he lives within a realm or he lives in a
state he exists in a state that is far
too large for our you know
meager universe you know he's unbound by
time and space he's eternal he cannot
manifest himself in this realm but in a
diminished form and so that is why he
came as a burning bush that's why he
descended on a mountain as a cloud
because he in his eternal fatherly state
it would for lack of a better word break
the game and so
every and that speaks to the the the
genius of god
everything everything has a very it's
not a trivial thing that he exists in a
trinity
let me let me i listen to you
respectfully right i didn't interrupt
you now um the question here gets to be
that you're saying things that are
contradictory if you say they're all
equal that means jesus while on earth if
he being fully god would have full
knowledge if jesus didn't know the hour
and the father did know the hour they're
no longer equal that doesn't make sense
right okay all right let me know when
you're finished let me know when you're
finished finish
okay all right so to your point that is
why is that why would that why would god
yeah no i'm saying you're here you're
telling you're telling me
the limitations or the boundaries or the
parameters under which god has to exist
tell me why and all all-powerful wait
tell me why an all-powerful all-knowing
being
be incapable of manifesting himself in
our realm exactly how he sees fit i got
you don no problem i got you listen can
you have a square circle
can you have a square circle no
okay why not
because if something is square it is not
a circle
thank you so if god is fully
knowledgeable and all capable and equal
in all three forms then he cannot be
ignorant of anything he is not happy
because now when jesus didn't know the
hour he obviously had knowledge that he
didn't have the father did have so that
means it cannot be a square circle god
cannot be all-knowing and not no but you
are you are active
hold on hold on
so the problem here gets to be is when
you say that on earth jesus was fully
god and you say according to the bible
that god knows everything so when god
doesn't know something that means like a
square circle he cannot be god because
by definition according the bible god
knows everything and when he doesn't
know the hour he doesn't know everything
so then you would have to say jesus on
earth was not fully god and you don't
say that so you have a contradiction in
your core critical belief
are you finished yes sir so i do not
have a contradiction because god jesus
is not separate from the father the and
they're not separate from the holy
spirit they all exist at once and so
they are all god and in the sense of
how can i put this the father exists
eternally
along with jesus and the holy spirit so
if god manifests himself as a human in
the form of jesus and he manifests
himself in
a way where he doesn't know
when the rapture will occur this does
not
automatically mean that jesus is not god
this is the human this is just a very a
variant of the human limitations that he
imposed upon himself that he took upon
himself for his own
reason we are we are it is not upon the
creation to try and understand why see
here's the mistake that you're making
you're making a mistake of assuming that
god could not manifest himself in our
world as a human unless he had all of
the characteristics that you a mere
human and a part of his creation has
seems worthy or seems fit that is no
different than the logic of the atheist
or the or the the modern day spiritual
person who says oh god if god was real
he would be like this or if god was real
he would feel like this if god was real
he wouldn't not like gay people because
how could a god not you're putting
you're creating your own and this is
breaking the second commandment thou
shalt not make a god in your image
you're making a god that can only exist
under the rules that you're feeble and
by feeble i mean like human we all have
feeble brains in the in comparison to
the to the mind of the father you're
you're you're trying to put god in a box
god is he works in mysterious ways so if
he chooses to manifest himself in that
capacity then it is not up to us the
question problem is don your own bible
is the one that makes that box and
you're blaming it on me read matthew
10 30.
and some of my comments said god could
make a square circle that is true that
is not true because by definition if you
make it into a circle it's no longer a
square and if you make it into a square
it's no longer a circle but by by your
definition that would mean that there's
something that god has been capable of
doing no no again which is contradictory
to what it is to mean to be god it can
do anything don't try to jump here
that's that's legit how could he be
there was something he was incapable of
doing
could god make a stone heavier than he
could lift
could god make a stone heavier than he
could lift yeah do you see what's wrong
with that question no that's a different
question that's a different question
don matthew 10 30. that's a different
and he could he it depends on how you
want to look at it because you know in
an in an essence in a way you know if he
had chosen to do that then yeah he could
do that you know but he wouldn't
necessarily do it in the way that you're
imagining if you look at
the question okay okay all right matthew
10 30. but the very ears of your head
are all numbered
keep going
okay but the very hairs of your head are
all no where do you want me to read you
amazing god is all-knowing he is aware
of everything about us everything we do
and everything we think and he knows
what goes on in private as well in
public right
all right but the very heads of hairs of
your head are all numbered so do not
fear you are more valuable than many
sparrows therefore everyone who
confesses me before men i will also
confess him before my father who is in
heaven but whoever this is what i'm
saying like
all right but whoever denies me before
men i will also deny him before my
father who is in heaven do not think
that i came to bring peace on earth i
did not come to bring peace but a sword
for i came to set a man against his
father
and a daughter against her mother and a
daughter-in-law against her
mother-in-law and a man's enemies will
be the members of his household he who
loves father or mother more than me is
not worthy of me and he who loves son or
daughter more than me is not worthy of
me and he who does not take his cross
and follow after me is not worthy of me
he who has found his life will lose it
and he who has lost his life for my sake
will find it
you said matthew you said matthew um
10 30.
30 right all right okay all right all
right all right you want me to keep
going you're good you're good no
understand
that according to the bible god knows
everything even all the hairs on your
head if you look at the macarthur bible
study guide right now under that verse
he tells you that god is all-knowing
everything that is to be known god knows
right right another thing gets to be is
when you say jesus didn't know the hour
and you say that god knows everything
then that is a contradiction that
doesn't make sense because either you
say that while jesus was on earth he was
no longer god and god the father was
superior to him if you say that okay
let's discuss that but if you don't then
the problem gets to be that if you say
they're equal and they have the same
then jesus not knowing the hour and the
father knowing the other hour no longer
makes them equal that is not true that
again you're breaking the second
commandment by making a god to fit your
own parameters by that logic just
because
just because jesus is not hungry he
can't be god you're ignoring the very
fact that they exist in unity in unison
at the same time there it's not as if
when jesus came to earth god the father
took a break or was on pause they all
three have existed eternally in
perpetuity
they are not the same they are not the
same let me be clear about that the son
is not the father the father is not the
holy spirit the holy spirit is not the
son but that is how it is set up it's
three persons one god and each person
has a different purpose in the same way
that the father didn't die upon the
cross the son did
there were things that
there are things that
one of them the only true god or no
they're all part of the true god they're
all they all are god they are it's one
god three persons god the father not the
son would you would you disagree with me
say that one more time if i told you no
the only true god is the father
would i disagree with you yes okay can
you open up john 17 3.
okay john
17 3.
okay
read it please
okay this is eternal life that they may
know you the only true god and jesus
christ whom you have sent
you see that now the father has been
called the only true god
and jesus christ whom you have sinned
they may get to know you the father and
not not the father and jesus christ whom
you sent the father said yes and we know
the father sent jesus the true god in
the bible which i just asked you would
you disagree with me and you did no this
is not this is no no let's all right
wait i want you to finish i want to
finish get it done we're having a good
conversation
a second ago i asked you if i said the
father is the only true god would you
disagree with you said yes now
in front of you saying that jesus is not
a part of the only true guy you get to
know you the only god
in that though
you sent let me finish don okay go ahead
verse is saying that the father is the
only true god and jesus was sent by the
only true god by you referring to the
only true god then jesus now excluded
from that and that goes against your
belief
okay so hold on wait wait wait wait one
guy's human you're assuming wait and let
me let me just read because everyone's
telling me that you're taking it matcha
telling me you're taking it out of
context so give me a second to let me
read
oh okay all right so the highly priestly
player jesus spoke these things and
lifted up his eyes to heaven he said
father your hours come glorify your son
that the son may glorify you even as you
gave him authority over all flesh to do
all whom you have given him he may give
eternal life this is eternal life that
they may know you the only true god in
jesus christ whom you've sent i have
glorified you on earth having the
accomplished yeah i see
well wait wait i'm trying to i'm trying
to this because i'm trying to decide for
the context
all
here
so wait let me let me let me read
because and again this is see i'm
i'm just looking at this as an
opportunity to
to get out of the contradiction
to get out of the contradiction but this
is giving me an opportunity so that i
can better evangelize some muslims in
the future when you you ask me questions
like this i'm very paying very close
attention to the things you're you're
focusing on um because and something you
have to also
understand something you have to
understand is that
these are entire books being written
like you asked me to jump to the middle
of a book
there's an entire context of the book
because all right let's let me watch
this you go to john chapter one verse
one go to john over and this is the
point i'm trying to make you see like
you want to jump to the middle of the
book you're not you know
edge i'm no i'm passionate i'm very
passionate you feel me but go ahead i'm
really i'm relaxed we'll go to john one
one no problem with that but the issue
here is the reason you're not responding
to my clear verse that contact server
let me finish it up i did respond i did
respond
since you said i didn't let me let me
let me let me say what i said you are
projecting you are projecting
onto the verse that is not said you are
saying just because you for whatever
reason i don't know
um where in this verse you feel like you
have the liberty to say that this means
that jesus is not a part of the godhead
just be you you the only true god in
jesus christ you whom you have said
thank you
and i said you read that and i infer
that jesus christ included that godhead
you read it and choose to infer that he
is not included in that godhead okay let
me let me say this again don if i told
you earlier that if i was to say that
the father is the only true god would
you agree and you said you would not
agree with that here jesus in context is
saying the father is the only true god
right so you are caught here because
right before you read the verse you said
that if i was to say that father is the
only true god you would disagree and
when jesus says the father is the only
true god now you have no response so you
want me to read john 1 1. no i just gave
you my response in case you miss if you
didn't
i didn't understand how jesus can say to
the father you're the only true god and
earlier when i said if i said that you
would disagree and now when jesus says
that why do you not disagree because you
are implying one there this entire book
is littered with verses where jesus is
affirming his deity one two this does
not say that i am not god this is this
says that you said he says you are the
only true god and jesus christ whom you
have sent so
since when does that
mean that how does that mean that jesus
is saying that he's not god done you are
choosing to you are choosing to read the
scripture in that manner john listen i
asked you earlier if i was to say the
father is the only true god would you
agree and you said you would disagree
the verse here jesus clearly tells the
father
just because you keep repeating it
doesn't mean it's true you see why do i
keep repeating it because you are
clearly caught from early no i'm not you
just because you keep repeating that
i've i've responded to you the exact
same time every time and you have not in
any logical or meaningful way
discredited what i've said there is
nothing in this verse that says that
jesus christ is not god you are choosing
there is nothing in this verse that says
that jesus christ is not god you are
choosing to eliminate who's in you're
choosing to infer that from this verse
because
you wanted to say that third person nico
how you doing bro i'm good are you done
good so
if i were to say that the father is the
only true god and don disagrees with
that he says i don't i don't agree with
that and then the bible jesus christ
says to the father you are the only true
god
do you see where the church
contradicts the bible see the
contradiction it's either that there's a
trinity or there's not a trinity
thank you so don even if you're going to
choose to close your eyes to the fact
that you just contradicted your own
bible doesn't mean that others watching
will as well the issue is i'm not
insinuating anything i made the exact
same statement that jesus makes in the
bible earlier and you disagreed with me
and when it's in the bible now you're
trying to jump from it that's the
problem you heard me make the exact i
use the exact same words look man i
don't need to if you want to interpret
the bible as such go right ahead i am
telling you that you are misinterpreting
the verse as it is read it is not my i
don't need to defend the bible the bible
says vengeance is mine and one day when
you die and you are in front of the
creator you will have to account for you
know taking his word out of context don
i've said this multiple times you cannot
explain to me how this you are assuming
you are assuming that because
jesus said you are the only true god and
jesus christ whom you have sent you are
choosing to take the word and and use it
as some kind of separator in my
experience with the english language and
in my experience whenever i use the word
and it is for the sake of unification
not for the sake of separation but you
want to take it like that go right ahead
brother i'm not going to argue with it
anymore if you want to move on john
chapter one first one go right ahead
before we leave before you say that
people in the chat are saying that i'm
setting you open it's a 61. i did not
bring him in uh faye had brought him in
i have never i've never heard of your
teaching before but i'm enjoying
listening to you talk this was not meant
to be a setup i thought this would be a
good conversation but this was not and
don you're willing to i'm willing to let
you bring in a christian historian right
now i'm not trying to make this like um
a set up this was not the intention at
all but yeah can i jump in really
quickly here so firstly i think dawn and
[ __ ] man are the only two talking
the other you know five of us have been
relatively silent i do want to say one
thing though so don just for your kind
of context jesus didn't speak english so
there's no point talking about english
but what is used is greek he didn't
speak greek but that's what's used in
the manuscripts so the word that he uses
is is theon i think that's how it's
pronounced deon and that's different
from theos theon is actually the
possessive meaning that it only belongs
to this person so that's the difference
between saying that you know
i'm an owner versus i'm the owner right
an owner suggests that there's others
which word in which wording because i
actually have um the greek a greek
translator right here so which word in
particular
no which word which english word were
you translating oh god the only true god
theon is basically the only true god
meaning that when he says the father is
theon and the only true god theon is
possessive meaning that own that title
only belongs to the father and even if
you wanted to for some reason even
though it goes against the grammar you
want it to include jesus in that because
he says and there's no holy spirit in
that
so at the very best even if you kind of
go against the grammar there and i'm not
a greek expert you know mm-hmm
all right so may i offer this then may i
offer this because there's a perspective
that um i don't think you guys are
taking into account
and and i'm actually and it's inspired
by the fact that you brought up that the
holy spirit was not mentioned so
if you understand this is under the
premise that
you understand that jesus is a part of
the godhead right
understand that the context in which
that these verses were being preached
what jesus was talking to they were
surrounded they were in a place filled
with pagan religions filled with people
worshipping other gods and so when jesus
is points to the father when he's
talking to the father he's not
separating himself from that he's not
separating the holy spirit from that
he's saying that this god which i am a
part of and again if we want to go back
no if you want to say that again you add
it into the verse there's no i'm a part
of you just added that into the verse no
but um no what i am saying is that we're
thinking
i don't know look if so look at this if
it's already been established by jesus
multiple times in the book leading up to
now that i am um i am in the father the
father is in me if you've seen the
father you have seen the if you've seen
me you've seen the father if he's
multiple times upon this point hammered
home that i am god and god and i are
there's a unity between us we are one in
the same
there's a degree of separation it is the
fact that he's the father i am the son
and then there's the holy spirit which
he goes on to speak about in i believe
chapter 19.
the point is when he's doing that he's
saying the god of those people over
there that is not the true god when he's
pointing to other gods eyes on the true
god when he points to the father he's
saying this true god and so he's not
separated there's a problem there's a
problem you're adding into the verse
when he says you are the only true god
he's not saying about other people or
other gods and then he says and jesus
christ who you sent no no wait hold on
hold on hold on hold on hold on bro
you can't add your own words into the
bible okay
no you you are because you're saying
that and means that he is separating
himself
did i say that he didn't say anybody and
separate he didn't say that how do you
get that
how do you get to the conclusion by that
sentence that they are separate
let me tell you hey don i don't even say
that all i said was i asked you when
it's recorded you can you can refine it
if you like
if if i was to say the father is the
only true god would you agree i didn't
say anything about jesus being a part of
him not being a part of him and and but
nothing but that is what you were
implying that's how i understood your
question i understood your question that
you were saying that if you could show
me a verse
let me finish when i said those exact
same words you disagreed you said father
is not the only true god when jesus
spoke this exact same word according to
you i don't even believe in the bible
i'm saying according to you
jesus said
we are just having a conversation
i wanna hear what he's saying for real
and that's finished i've never done that
once when any of them
i'm just listening right now i'm not
even religious
i just want to listen i don't want to
hear finish the sentence on
thank you
okay so the issue that gets to be is
when i made a statement the exact same
statement that's in the bible exact same
words then you got caught and now you're
jumping no
you you are one
you were just having a conversation
about the trinity right
the only point i was making the only
point i was making was that all three
are part of the trinity that unity is
god right one god three persons
you then
asked me you asked me oh if there is a
verse that no i didn't i did not say
that i said if i was to say please
remember my words if i was to say that
the father is the only true god would
you agree you said i would disagree now
jesus says
i'm good bro go watch go watch the
recording again it's been great talking
to you guys uh check out the one message
foundation channel you can see a lot
more of the videos there it's niko when
you're ready to become muslim give me a
hula and uh don when you go through
researching the bible and the studies
and the contradictions and you're ready
to become muslim give me a call great
talking to you guys
nice to meet you
don you were cutting him off a lot man
yeah bro because he takes thing he's one
he's very manipulative the way i don't
think so i think you feel like you're
being manipulated because he's
no because he we're talking about
trinity the point we're making about the
trinity is that it's three gods and one
he then asked me a question he don't
even get to finish his points like i
wanted to hear what he had to say and
you weren't giving him a fair chance to
speak you're interrupting me now just
like how you were interrupting him yeah
bro because he said the same three times
you want him to hear say the same thing
seven times bro i he asked me a question
i respond to him he doesn't address my
answer and then he just keeps repeating
it over and over again and then he and
then he will he's trying to move on and
say see i caught you in a contradiction
without addressing the fact that that
verse does not say that jesus christ is
not god and so then when i try to press
him further to get clarity right all of
a sudden he's like oh no i wasn't saying
that you know there was a verse where he
was saying jesus wasn't god and so he
what he's trying to do is get me into
like a parlor trick in regards to
semantics when well the essence well
then let that happen let him finish the
sentence and then you can you could
respond with that but i didn't even get
to fully hear what he had to say and i
was interested because he seems like a
religious expert i'm having a mom
there's a lot of people listening i
understand that you have a lot of
conviction on what you believe in but
you have to give a fair place to hear
both sides i know that you believe that
the bible is everything but let this is
a plate this is my stream too like i
want to hear both sides of the
discussion and i know like this is this
is not like a bible stream i want to
hear both sides it's a place to have
fair debate and what you were doing
right now was not fair to be
interrupting him like that is not the
proper way to have a conversation you
can't he can't twist my words and he
wasn't twisting your words
though he was going off your own logic
he was going off the things that you
were saying about the trinity and about
how no but
don i think maybe maybe for another
stream right it might be better if you
find a scholar that you like maybe
someone or if you know any get in
contact with them we'll try and uh set
up a date and maybe you can get someone
that you trust that can perceive
they can say how you want to say because
i'll be honest having five of us
yeah i didn't have a problem i didn't
have a problem with someone who knew
more than me in terms of like oh grown
to this one this is clearly not his
first time doing this and so he caught
me in a trap not a contradiction he
called me in a semantic trap where he
was
we were speaking right and this is this
is the problem he was disingenuous we
were speaking about the trinity right
and so he brings up this this this verse
right to try and what refute the trinity
but and he words his question in a very
specific way as if to say that this
verse right if i can find you a verse
that proves that jesus is not god the
holy spirit is not god that there is
only one true god then you would have to
admit that there is a problem with the
bible i'm like who bet he brings us to
this verse this verse does not in any
essence any way say that jesus is not
god and then what he's trying to figure
out freaks are like fixate on he's
fixating on the the three words oh jesus
saying only true god but if this verse
in no way
takes away from jesus's godhood in no
way proves that jesus
he's not god why not show me how he does
that can i i i think i think i'll make
one point on this if no one has anything
else to say and then we can move on
back and forth
before
before you go on i just i wanna let
y'all know man you gotta go to sleep i
understand bro have a good night
sleep tight sleep tight
you don't need to say it don't worry
about it it's okay it's 3am yo like
y'all i love y'all for the sake of god
but i gotta go i gotta hit the night
prayer and get some sleep so
peace out
bro
bro bro
by the way man
i just want you know that even though it
it started to get like real heated
i still think it's all cool man
yeah bro i have no i have no ill
feelings towards anybody here on this
panel but this dude i really do feel
like he was implementing some snake you
say this a lot of the time
you say this a lot even when i had luke
balmar and you go back and forth and
when you feel like they're doing snake
tactics you feel like it's justified to
interrupt them and not let them finish
their point because you see the cut but
that's not a fair way to have a
conversation it doesn't even have to be
a debate that's not the right word but
it's it's not it's not pleasing to
listen to going back and forth like that
you've done that before when you think
that somebody's a grifter but i think he
was coming from a genuine place and i
want to have him on the stream again not
fate if i can have him out again like in
the future yeah like we'll do it with
the setup and i think
it's i think that you should have like a
christian scholar on i don't want people
to just think this is a setup a lot of
people might have saying el fran del
friend once again i didn't even know who
this guy was his name was i didn't know
who he was i initially started the
stream to talk with the three muslims
channel to talk about like um the hit
piece that went out about me
disrespecting islam if this turned into
a christian uh islam comparison but this
is not what the initial point of the
conversation was that was not my
intention don do you think i'm a l man
i do feel like you lowkey you this is
loki what you wanted bro what yo did i
did i know that he was coming on you you
heard him say he was bringing him on
listen listen
on our channel on our youtube channel
it's not it's not it's it's like
yeah
it's good bro yeah on our youtube
channel the three muslims all we want to
do is bring on educated people not
people that are wafflers not people that
deal with contradictions and we like
learning people not in just one religion
but in multiple religions and all i all
wanted to do was bring on shaykh with
mon and just hear him out that's it and
i didn't get to hear him out don what do
you think that i did was wrong we
weren't even they're saying it's a setup
but we were not even talking we were
listening we weren't like interjecting i
was just listening to you go back and
forth we barely we didn't even say a
word
bro that dude did not come on here
having a genuine conversation bro he
came on here he was implant
employing um
like he he was
he was not having a genuine conversation
he did not want and it looks like how i
asked you since since because every time
oh no you got you oh you got you that's
you the whole time please explain i
didn't say that i never said that once
every time oh no you got you got
conscious so tell me he asked me no he
didn't say i never said he got you he
asked me a genuine question
good since you can you please explain to
me how john
verse 17 chapter 17 verse 3
explains that jesus christ is not god
could you explain that to me that's not
the point i was making
this never mind he was making i don't
remember one thing is here right i think
that that um shake with man i think he's
definitely more educated on his religion
than you currently are on yours so
that's why i'm saying don't you think it
would be better if you was to bring on a
more educated christian that can argue
with it i don't think it was
manipulative i just think he knows his
religion better than you know yours but
i also think he knows christianity
better too that's not the issue the
issue is can we understand this one
verse and what it means that was the
whole problem and that's why i kept
cutting him off because he kept he kept
trying to act as if
i conceded that this verse says that
jesus is not god and my argument kept
being no you have not in any way show me
how chapter 17 verse 3 or the book of
john is proof that jesus christ is not a
part of the godhead so tom what is how
was that my fault
because when i tried to push back on
that because he wanted to move on trying
to act as if i conceded that you kept
you kept defending him i never defended
him he asked me a question does it sound
like he contradicted himself with the
trinity i said yes i never said gotcha i
never did that once that's how you felt
so how did it contradict the trinity
explain that because you were saying
that the god god is all one person at
the same time god is all-knowing but at
the same time jesus said father is
all-knowing and that sounds like a
contradictory to me because of jesus but
if jesus was a person then he's also
all-knowing that's what i said sounds
like a contradiction i wasn't trying to
get you it was asking about john we were
talking about john 17 verse 3. he asked
you if that was a contradiction you were
quick to say yes i'm asking you how is
it a contradiction for what i just said
because you started up the conversation
hold up you said you started the
conversation by the trinity means that
god is all these people god is
all-knowing and god is three things in
one and then you also said that jesus is
not jesus as a person and jesus looked
up to father god and that sounds like a
contradiction to me
one that is not what i said who that's
what he said that was the question he
asked me no that was and and see that's
the thing and then this is what i mean
by other people am i being just a
genuine right now i'm saying no i'm not
i'm saying that that does not address at
all the verse that we were talking about
the verse that he tried to build his
argument on the fact that you're not
even addressing that verse is my point
and that's why i was getting frustrated
and that's what i was okay because
what's the verse then now he's he left
the call he felt like he were
interrupting him now that you're not
even addressing that versus my point and
that's why i was getting frustrated and
that's what i was okay because what's
the verse then now he's off he left the
call he felt like you were interrupting
him now you have the time can you let's
let's dissect it
okay all right so i know bro feel free
to sleep tight bro
for real but before i dip i got a
question for y'all y'all like bread
yeah
yo listen y'all ever had some french
bruschette the bruschetta bread that's
that's yeah yeah yeah
listen y'all want that real sub bro you
got to come out to france i never had
bread like this before
that's all i got to say but anyways
okay i can't find another time but y'all
don't want to go good night all
if you guys uh don't feel like saying
but i want to break this down now i want
to read this yeah no i'm in i'm in i'm
here okay john can you read the verse
okay this is eternal life that they may
know you the only true god and jesus
christ christ whom you have
sent what about that verse
how does that verse
separate jesus christ from the godhead
i didn't realize that's what he brought
up i thought he was talking about the
fact that jesus said god is all-knowing
is that not what that says in the bible
did jesus not say that god is
all-knowing
no he didn't say that okay then he's
wrong but that's what i thought he was
saying
god is all-knowing did jesus say that
god is all-knowing i mean there may be a
verse where he has said okay knows all
things okay that's what i think is a
contradiction in the bible if there's
three of them and then jesus also says
father is all-knowing then he's
all-knowing and he's a person that
sounds like a contradiction to me i
think it's separate from that specific
bible verse that you're bringing up
right now
and the that specific one all right so
we can address that those are two
separate things one
you so you see my issue with this verse
how this verse in no way separates jesus
from the godhead okay maybe maybe that
verse but you're also saying that
there's other verses that say that maybe
that no no no but i you asked me if g if
god is all knowing right i said yes the
father is unknown you asked me is there
a verse where jesus specifically says
the father is on all knowing i say i'm
not sure i don't know okay he may he may
not but either way we know he is the
bible definitely says that for sure that
the father is all-knowing
and to my what i was trying to explain
to you i was trying to explain earlier
how the trinity is jesus is not the
father only the father is all-knowing
and so but don't you see the
contradiction if you're saying that
they're all the same but also jesus is
not the father they are they are not the
same i that's how i remember earlier in
the call you said that they all the
three and one no i'm saying they're all
the same god they're all a part there's
three persons one god each person
god is a person
he's three persons in one
if god requires part then god would be
incomplete without parts correct no here
again is an example of breaking the
second commandment you're deciding the
jurisdictions that and the
characteristics that god has to have
you're saying that oh god could only
exist in this capacity in this form he's
god he chooses to exist how he wants to
exist and he he knows exactly why he
does that he's chosen to manifest
himself in the form of a human as jesus
christ here but we also know that from
the bible right and this is the verse i
was trying to get him to go to because
this is the thing that
his only argument against the bible is
trying to misinterpret verses to try and
say that there are contradictions but
i'm sure he's read the bible and he
knows exactly what john chapter 1 verse
1 says which is where i was trying to go
where it says in the beginning was the
word and the word word was with god and
the word was god and then when you go
down a little bit further it says and
then the word became flesh and dwelt
among us and so that's how we know that
jesus
in this instance was the word okay but
don would you be down to set up another
i i want it to be fair let's set up
another debate in the future how about
in two days or three days we could do it
and that doesn't even have to be a
debate it could be a healthy
conversation about the differences
between the bible and the quran
no i have no interest in that okay then
we won't do it then we won't do it you
don't have to do it yeah i saw that you
had on this muslim panel i came on here
to ask questions about islam i did not
come on here to have a debate between
christianity and all now i think you
turned it i think you turned it into a
debate no no i
i didn't bring bro on here to try and
question me about um oh what about this
this oh there you go you you came on to
question them he came on to question you
what's the difference he came on to try
and prove that the bible is flawed i i
what all now i don't have the one answer
we've been on stream for what almost he
was going to do that regardless of
whether he was here or not done it it's
one question and he even got that
question i asked how do you get
salvation how do you go to heaven in
islam oh now i ain't got nothing
done
i came on here to genuinely learn and
get because that's a criticism i've
gotten a lot from my muslim viewers you
have not asked a muslim about islam
notice how broke came on we did not talk
a lick about islam all he tried to do
was chew
stuff out of context out of the bible
all he tried to do was spin the bible
and try to say oh they're contributions
have i ever sneaked in talking about god
try to to undermine islam saying oh look
what about this verse in the quran and
this verse in the quran and this all i
mean i don't know if you want like i
brought this before in the last room
that we talked about religion and you
got angry at me for saying it on the
stream but i already said it but you you
did tell me and i don't want you to get
mad at me or call me a snake but you did
say that islam is a false religion yes
that's what i'm talking about i stand by
that but that
he brought that up i got mad at you in
the context of we were talking to a
muslim and i
my goal is not to debate or prove
muslims wrong my only goal in doing any
of this is spreading the gospel and it
is not wise to try and spread the gospel
to someone after you've insulted them
about something that they care deeply
about okay you should question your
beliefs now you should question your
religion
okay so you came on here to question
islam you have three muslims above you
right now why don't you ask some
questions